I have been itching to
deep clean this pool
ever since we moved in here about
18 months ago
and my husband has always vetoed
any plans that I've had to
deep clean around the pool
and as much as I hate to admit it
he's probably right
probably not the best idea to water blast a
whole lot of gunk into a full pool
but now that it's empty I cannot tell you
how excited I am
I have been waiting for this day
and not just cause I find water blasting
extremely fkn cathartic on its own
and not just cause I knew that these
grout lines were gonna come up so good
but and I hate the term but I would consider
myself a clean freak right
so I was sitting poolside all summer long
last summer watching the kids
and I swear all I could see was this
grotty as grout
and whenever I was in the pool
or maybe sitting on the edge of the pool
or in the spa
I was .. disgusted if I'm honest
don't already know we are
insane
we're currently DIY pool renovating
a 50 year old pool with no pool renovation experience
and these I believe are the original bricks
so most will be 50 years old
they have seen some things
I imagine that they've had a good life
a few have been replaced
and many of them have big chips and gouges taken out of them
just the wear and tear of a space well loved
But they’re also covered in mould and algae
mineral deposits probably pool chemicals
sunscreen and organic materials from just the weather
after so long of wanting to do it
it felt so good to give them a good deep clean
we've been battling this algae infestation ever since we moved in
constantly scrubbing it adjusting the chemicals
but now that it's drained
I was able to really get in there and give it a good blast off
it felt so good but until we reseal this plaster
which we will in another video
we'll just keep battling this issue because the
concrete is porous at the moment
and so the algae just lives inside the holes
and just keeps coming back?
by the way I didn't know if I was just tripping
but at the start of this the pool was most
definitely white right
but I swear if you look at it now
you can see blue peeking through
which makes me think that it must have been blue once
and then maybe it was painted
but pretty much all of that white paint is gone anyway
cause in so many spots it's just bare concrete anyway
in the last video we chipped off all of those tiles
I'll link it in the caption if you wanna go back and watch
cause that was oddly satisfying
now we're priming all around the waterline
ready to lay our new tiles
quick reminder of where we started
and this is where we've got to
here's a sneak peek of the tile
and I'm posting in real time
so I'm so sorry but come back soon